hey Travis
look who decided to call has there been
another murder uh-huh uh uh actually
hit me with that unique rom-com sequel
this is not a sequel
number one suspect is the bride Zoe's
sister
Grace didn't do it we got a dead body
and a whole lot of people to talk to
your name you fine as hell Travis
we'd like to hear your accounts of what
happened I like to call them your mind
movies
it was all trouble and for the record
the case wasn't the only thing that was
hard oh God
everyone here had a motive
I have
many tales to tell actually maybe let's
just start from the beginning of the
wedding I'm a Searcher okay
Edgar's crumb and Grace knows that I'm
was that pretty handy with a broom that
was a broom that's how I can tell you've
never swept before it's like a
lightsaber
well it's actually my adoption day I
don't know when I was born
this looks delicious that's potpourri oh
bon appetit
we know you're eating air freshener
anyone could have done it
and my mother says hello
[Music]
she went to be here but she was busy
with silence and alcohol
let us raise a toast to the happy couple
this whole thing is so much more complex
than you guys realize
we all have our
s well I think it's pretty clear that's
not our guy what did you say you got or
not not what
[Music]
you kill that girl
not rich white people whisper is never a
good thing